Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube và Excel khóa học
miễn phí này dành cho những ai mới bắt
đầu học Excel hoặc những người chưa
thành thạo cần hệ thống lại kiến thức
của mình Trước tiên mình cùng tìm hiểu
các nội dung sẽ có trong khóa học này
hóa học gồm 26 video được thiết kế chi
tiết từ cơ bản nhất đến nâng cao nhất để
ai cũng có thể hiểu và thực hành được
nội dung gồm bài mở đầu Excel là gì Tại
sao lại là Excel tiếp theo là bài số 1
mình sẽ làm quen với các thao tác với
file Excel Bài số 2 mình sẽ đi vào một
ví dụ cụ thể là nhập liệu để cùng làm
quen với các thành phần của Excel từ bài
số 3 đến bài số 8 mình sẽ tìm hiểu các
hàm Excel quan trọng nhất như là hàm
Vlookup hlookup hành điều kiện ít hàng
tính cổng hành đếm vân vân từ video thứ
9 đến video thứ 13 là các cái kỹ năng
Excel quan trọng nhất như kỹ năng về
định dạng theo định dạng có điều kiện
a castle kỹ năng lọc và sắp xếp hay các
tính năng khác từ bài số 14 biến bài số
17 mình sẽ cùng tìm hiểu về các thủ
thuật Excel hay và Hữu Dũng nhấn nhá và
số 18 là vẽ biểu đồ bài số 19 là in ấn
bài số 20 là Vios thấy bồ bài số 21 là
công thức mảng bài số 22 tạo báo cáo
động dashboard bài số 23 mình sẽ tìm
hiểu các phím tắt thích sao thông dụng
giúp cải thiện cái năng suất làm việc
của các bạn bài Số 24 là warner bros và
bài số 2 năm là bài cuối cùng mình sẽ
tìm hiểu về lập trình vba trong Excel
Vậy thì ít ra là gì Tại sao lại là Excel
Bill Gates tỷ phú giàu nhất thế giới
chia sẻ trong một buổi gặp gỡ toàn thể
nhân viên của Microsoft
a85 phần trăm nhân viên giỏi là những
người thành thạo Excel và các công cụ
tin học văn phòng khác các nhà quản lý
sẽ không đánh giá bạn qua Tấm bằng đại
học mà qua các chứng chỉ tin học và
ngoại ngữ bạn sẽ kiếm được không dưới
1.000 đô nếu bạn chỉ cần 5 phút để làm
báo cáo tài chính trên Excel Ngoài ra có
một câu chuyện vui thế này có một anh
chàng chuyên Dạy Excel khuyên mọi người
rằng nếu bạn giỏi Excel đừng khoe với ai
không thì khổ lắm đơn giản bởi vì rất
nhiều người đã hỏi anh ta các vấn đề
liên quan đến Excel nhiều đến nỗi Anh ta
không có thời gian và tập trung được vào
công việc của mình nữa vậy thì ít sau là
gì Excel hay còn gọi là Microsoft Excel
là một chương trình xử lý bảng tính của
Microsoft để giúp ghi lại Trình bày các
thông tin xử lý dưới dạng bảng thực hiện
tính toán và xây dựng các số liệu thống
kê trực quan có trong bảng từ Excel bảng
tính của Excel bao gồm nhiều ô được tạo
bởi các dòng và cột với nhiều tính năng
ưu việt và có giao diện rất
ở với người dùng Vậy thì tại sao lại cần
học Excel 90 phần trăm các nhà quản lý
giỏi trên thế giới dùng Excel để quản
trị càng ở những công ty lớn phần mềm
Pixel càng được ứng dụng nhiều từ lập
báo cáo thống kê Phân tích số liệu lọc
dữ liệu chuyển đổi dữ liệu tính toán vân
vân Excel ứng dụng cho nhân viên văn
phòng kế toán xây dựng hành chính nhân
sự xuất nhập khẩu Logistic kỹ sư vân vân
tất cả nhiều bộ phận nhiều ngành nghề
khác nhau đều dùng Excel Theo thống kê
trên kênh YouTube và Excel thì Excel
được học ở mọi độ tuổi không tính trẻ em
học nhiều nhất là những người đang đi
làm thứ hai là sinh viên hoặc sinh viên
mới ra trường và người đi làm lâu năm
ngoài ra thì có rất nhiều các chú các
bác mà trên 65 tuổi cũng học Excel số
lượng này chiếm gần một phần trăm thống
kê này để các bạn thấy rằng Excel rất là
quan trọng và hầu như mọi lứa tuổi mọi
ngành nghề Kể cả bạn làm cho công ty hay
các bạn làm tự do các bạn đều phải dùng
Excel
ở một số lưu ý giúp bạn học Excel hiệu
quả hơn thứ nhất là các bạn nên chọn cái
độ phân giải HD khi xem các bạn sẽ tích
và cái hình bánh răng ở góc phải dưới
video nhá Sau đó các bạn vào cái phần
quay live rồi các bạn sẽ chọn cho mình
là 720p hoặc là 1080 p Đây là cái chất
lượng HD thì giúp bạn xem được cái video
với chất lượng tốt nhất thứ hai bạn có
thể điều chỉnh tốc độ để phù hợp với nhu
cầu của bạn thì các bạn sẽ vào cái hình
bánh răng rồi các bạn sẽ chọn cái
libexpat các bạn có thể điều chỉnh tốc
độ Nga mặc định nó ở chế độ Noel Tức là
cái chế độ mà các bạn đang nghe này các
bạn có thể điều chỉnh tăng lên bằng cách
là tăng 1.25 1.5 hoặc 1.75 và tối đa là
tăng lên hai lần hoặc các bạn có thể
giảm tốc độ bằng cách các bạn sẽ chọn
vào 0.7 50.520 chống 25 nhá Đấy cái thứ
ba là các bạn cần cài đặt bộ gõ tiếng
Việt Thì mình khuyên các bạn nên dùng
cái bộ gõ unikey nhá lại các bạn sẽ vào
cái trình duyệt này các bạn
Ừ ok
hai.vn lại sau đó các bạn tích vào cái
mục Download Unikey Vì vào cái phiên bản
Windows của các bạn để các bạn tải về
nhá thì ở đây là Windows 10 Windows 7
Windows XP 32 bit Windows 10 Windows 7
XP 64 bit thì thông thường Bây giờ các
máy tính hay cài lại Windows 10 64 bit
thì các bạn sẽ thích bởi Đây là các bạn
tải về nhá sau khi các bạn tải về các
bạn cài đặt để có thể sử dụng được
Unikey nhá thì ở đây mình đang sử dụng
cái như kia rồi lại các bạn chửi nha các
bạn tích vào đây nếu như bạn thích mà
một lần nữa thì nó sẽ có chữ E là tiếng
Anh các bạn thích và một lần nữa là có
chữ v tiếng Việt thì nếu như mà muốn gõ
tiếng Việt thì các bạn sẽ tích vẫn đây
khi nào mới hiện chữ v ở đây thì nghĩa
là các bạn có thể gọi là tiếng Việt nhá
ngoài ra ấy tốt nhất là các bạn sẽ cài
cái phiên bản Excel mới nhất là Excel
2019 hoặc tối thiểu là Excel 2016 nhá
thì những cái bảng excel mới thì nó sẽ
có các bạn nhiều tính năng hơn nếu như
các bạn không thể cài được thì còn cũng
không ảnh hưởng nhiều đâu
Lê Thị trong cái loạt video này mình sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn trên cái phiên bản
Excel 2019 nhé Nếu như các bạn không thể
nâng cấp được thì các bạn cũng đừng quá
lo lắng Bởi vì trong cái loạt bài này ấy
thì các kiến thức cơ bản là giống nhau
các bạn bè có thể áp dụng được lưu ý
tiếp theo là các bạn cần tại cái file
thực hành và làm bài tập hoặc là các câu
hỏi trong phần mô tả phía dưới video nhá
thì các bạn chú ý nhá Ở dưới video các
bạn sẽ thấy cái mục xem thêm ở đây này
các bạn sẽ thích vào cái sâu nho thì
thông thường thì cái link tải file thực
hành mình sẽ để ở dưới đây các bạn sẽ
tích vào cái link bên cạnh để các bạn có
thể tải về nhá
ạ sau đó các bạn sẽ thích vào cái biểu
tượng download ở đây để các bạn tải về
nhá
Tôi lấy ví dụ ở đây mình sẽ là sẽ file
cái file mà mình đính kèm cho các bạn sẽ
thường là cái file nén nhá Giả sử đây là
cái file mà sau khi các bạn tải về các
bạn sinh nhá được phải các bạn sẽ chọn
access đấy thì đây là cái folder của cái
file mà các bạn tải về với một bài học
thì mình sẽ gửi đính kèm cho các bạn cái
link tải file nhá sau khi các bạn tải về
các bạn sẽ tích vào các bài học tương
ứng nhá thông thường trong cái bài học
tương ứng mình sẽ có một cái file thực
hành và một cái hoa là câu hỏi thì các
bạn phải tích vào cái câu hỏi để các bạn
trả lời các bạn làm bài tập về nhà nhá
Ngoài ra thì trước cái link tải file
thực hành mình sẽ để cái link các file
trong cái loạt bài này nhá các bạn chú ý
trong khóa học này mình sẽ có 26 video
Tức là trong cái phần này mình sẽ để
tương ứng là 26 cái link của các video
Nếu như các bạn cần vào cái video nào
thì các bạn chỉ cần kích chọn vào đây
thôi là được nhé
và cuối cùng là nếu như các bạn chưa
đăng ký Kênh Tức là cái nút sub like
hoặc cái 1 đăng ký mà nó màu đỏ thì các
bạn sẽ tích và các nút subcribe để các
bạn có thể cập nhật được video mới nhất
và đặc biệt là các bạn tích vào cái
subcribe để quạt ủng hộ gái Excel giúp
gái xe có động lực làm các video tiếp
theo nhé Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc
bài giới thiệu ở đây hẹn gặp lại các bạn
ở bài tiếp theo là bài số 1 các thao tác
cơ bản với file Excel Xin chào và hẹn
gặp lại à